I have something great and horrible for you
today and it's a case study in how an unfounded,
totally speculative panic causing conspiracy
theory can get itself going.
And how Fox news helps Republicans do it.
Wacky, extremist Republican Senator Tom cotton
went on Fox business and was interviewed by
Trump Brown nose or Maria Bartiromo about
the Corona virus. We've covered Corona virus.
It's an infectious disease which originated,
believed at a market in [inaudible] China.
Many countries including the United States
are dealing with some cases less deadly percentage
wise than SARS, but many more cases than SARS
and it's a real issue with serious consequences.
Cotton goes on Fox business and says, listen,
that Wu Han market is close to a Chinese lab
where we don't know what they're doing, and
Maria Bartow Romo keeps it going with questions
like, wait, we don't know what they're doing.
They're wait, the lab is right near the market
that is supposedly the source of the Corona
virus and of course there's no evidence for
anything that Tom cotton is implying. Here,
check out this irresponsible screed and then
we'll discuss it.
I have to get to the bottom of that. We also
know that just a few miles away from that
food market is China's only biosafety level
four super laboratory. That research is human
infectious diseases. Now we don't have evidence
that this disease originated there, but because
of China's duplicity and dishonesty from the
beginning, we need to at least ask the question
to see what the evidence says. And China right
now is not giving any evidence on that question
at all. So,
so this super lab that you refer to, this
super lab is the only one of its kind in this
area in Wu Han in the province, uh, that,
that area. And, and what do they do with the
super lab?
It's unclear, Maria. We have such laboratories
ourselves in the United States run by our
military in large part done for preventative
purposes, are trying to discover vaccines
or to protect our own soldiers. China's obviously
very secretive about what happens at the Wu
Han laboratory. We don't know again where
this virus originated. That's why it's so
important that we at least ask the questions
and get the evidence. But China continues
to block our ability to ask those questions
and get that evidence. So
the key line there is we don't have evidence
that the disease originated in this lab. That's
actually all you need to say. That should
end the conversation. But Maria Bartiromo
says, you're saying this is the only lab like
it in China and it's right there next to the
Wu Han market, and he says, yeah, and we don't
even know what it is that they do at this
lab. Well, that's also not evidence of anything
and Maria Bartiromo should do the responsible
thing and say, Senator, is there any evidence
for what you're implying here? And the answer
would be no. Instead, Maria Bartiromo says,
wow, the only lab of it's kind of right there
just stoking this totally fact free conspiracy
theory from Tom cotton. Tom cotton is citing
this vague circumstantial thing while during
the Russia probe days, remember that Tom cotton
didn't find it circumstantially suspicious.
That endless of Trump's team had contacted
the Russians and lied about it and tried to
hide it.
That was a circumstantial case, not at all
suspicious to Tom cotton here. Totally without
evidence suggesting that the latest flulike
disease may be a Chinese bio weapon, not only
willing to put it out there, but helped along
by Maria Bartiromo on Fox business. Now in
case you care, this idea has already been
discussed and debunked. It is true that there
is a well known lab and Wu Han. It's a cellular
cellular level, biosafety level four lab.
There is a a statement from Richard [inaudible],
bright professor of chemical biology at Rutgers
who says, quote, there's absolutely nothing
in the genome sequence of this virus that
indicates the virus was engineered. The possibility
this was a deliberately released bio weapon
can be firmly excluded. Now additionally,
why would the Chinese create a bio weapon
that is mostly killing Chinese people is a
question, but then Tom cotton sort of tries
to backtrack and says, well, I'm not saying
it was developed on purpose in the lab, but
maybe accidentally tweeting a number of possibilities
where number two was good science, bad safety.
In other words, they were researching things
like diagnostic testing and vaccines, but
an accidental breach occurred. Once again,
it's hugely irresponsible if Republicans are
furious that sitting Senator Amy Klobuchar
didn't know the name of the Mexican president,
we talked about that yesterday, then they
should be endlessly more furious. That is
sitting Senator Tom cotton is eagerly willing
to spread panic and disinformation like this.
They don't care. They don't care. And Tom
cotton continues to do it. Helped along by
the way, by Fox news as Maria Bartiromo, who
was, she used to be a good financial reporter
interviewing CEOs on the floor of the New
York stock exchange 15 years ago when I started
getting into the stock market 20 years ago,
even she has become a Trump Brown nose, Brown
noser and a perpetuator of disinformation.
Um, uh, that that is, um, it's sad and also
very frustrating to see because she could
still be a good journalist and instead she
does this stuff.
Donald Trump had what we call an upper mourning.
There's upper Trump and downer. Trump upper
Trump is the Trump that tweets uncontrollably
and Trump this morning, tweeting again and
again and again and again. Everything from
conspiracy theories to disinflation to wild
attacks on people. And I want to remind you
that this is not normal and we have to balance
at the David Pakman show. I think everybody
has a responsibility to balance. On the one
hand, we don't want to publicize what Trump
says on Twitter as reasonable presidential
speech, but we also can't ignore that while
other world leaders and past American presidents
have focused on doing their jobs, we now have
a president whose feed is indistinguishable
from a sort of weird blend of Alex Jones conspiracy
theorist and Breitbart right wing propagandists.
So let's check it out first talking about
once again the Roger Stone trial and the judge
Amy Berman, Jackson quoting from of course
Fox and friends this morning saying quote,
judge Jackson now has a request for a new
trial based on the unambiguous and self outed
bias of the foreperson of the jury who's also
a lawyer by the way.